natalie are you so soured on love
because this album to me says
this is what i said to myself when i
listen to it natalie's had it with
[ __ ] dudes
that's it she's done like she's just so
pissed
is that true are you never i mean with
covet i guess you can't date but when we
get out of this pandemic
are you open to the idea of romance or
are you completely bitter
no i'm not bitter at all um i'm open to
it but i'm also it's really hard to
imagine
because it's been over 20 years
and so i don't know to even imagine it
feels
really strange like do i don't even feel
like i know how to flirt
i wouldn't know if someone was flirting
with me
i don't know what would i feel like like
if some when when or if somebody makes a
move but i'm definitely not
closed off to it i'm closed off to
marriage but you don't know you meet
somebody great and
you know you you kind of go well i
really don't have a problem
being with myself and this has been good
that's been the longest
you know since i started having
boyfriends or whatever this is
definitely the longest stretch that i've
never
had anybody and i'm not upset about it
no you're not flipping out i wonder who
you're going to be with i think it's
going to be someone famous i think
you're going to end up probably
going to be well okay i've got it
narrowed down to two are you ready
go ahead all right robin robin knows um
jake gyllenhaal oh every girl says that
yes
yeah and then um silver linings playbook
bradley bradley cooper there you go yeah
i could hook you up with bradley cooper
he'll come over
okay right all right suddenly kobe's out
the window all of a sudden she's dating